cuando tenía seis años un hombre intentó
abusar sexualmente de mí
un obrero que estaba trabajando en una
construcción en mi casa me pidió que lo
ayudara a lijar una puerta y yo accedí
feliz se paró detrás mío para enseñarme
cómo hacerlo y después de un rato
comenzó a pegarse contra mi cuerpo y a
frotarse contra mí cuando le pregunté
qué estaba haciendo desabrochó mi
pantalón y comenzó a tocarme
lo que acaban de escuchar era el
comienzo de una de las primeras
versiones de esta presentación había
quedado completamente descartado hasta
que lo volvía a leer y hubo una parte
que me dejó helada
saben cuál
les doy una pista no es la parte en la
que digo que un hombre adulto me tocó
contra mi voluntad cuando yo era sólo
una niña sino lo que digo justo antes de
eso si no lo escucharon lo diré una vez
más cuando tenía seis años un hombre
intentó abusar sexualmente en mí
sean gente de lo que he dicho porque
dije intento y no simplemente que abusó
sexualmente de mí
llevo años escribiendo sobre violencia
sexual y de género pero aquí estoy la
supuesta escritora feminista
reproduciendo las mismas formas
limitadas de entender la agresión sexual
contra las que siempre protesto
el tema es que estoy segura que no soy
la única a la que le sucede esto vamos a
hacer un experimento
que imaginan ustedes cuando escuchan las
palabras agresión sexual
tómense un segundo y conjura en una
imagen en su cabeza
la tienen estoy segura de que en este
auditorio deben haber mil respuestas
distintas pero voy a animarme a ensayar
una que quizás compartan muchos de
ustedes quizás imaginen una violación
que va más o menos así una mujer que
grita pelea forcejea y patea
rabiosamente contra un hombre que se
impone violentamente sobre ella y tal
vez la golpea tal vez sujeta sus manos
con fuerza detrás de su cabeza para que
ella deje de resistirse a la amenaza con
un cuchillo para que para evitar
acerté
si esto es así quizás sea porque esta es
la imagen de las agresiones sexuales que
solemos ver por ejemplo en las películas
y que son terribles y definitivamente
reales
pero qué harían si les dijera que muchas
de las historias de violencia y agresión
sexual no se parecen en nada a la que
acabo de narrar
si les dijera que ella dijo que no pero
no lo dijo con tanta firmeza y bueno
creo que todos sabemos lo que nos han
dicho toda la vida que es que las
mujeres decimos que no cuando en verdad
queremos decir que sí
o si les dijera que ella dijo que no
pero mientras tanto continuaba
quitándose la ropa
pensarían en estos casos como formas de
agresión y violencia sexual
el problema es que muchos de nosotros
tenemos una idea no equivocada pero sí
profundamente limitada de lo que es la
violencia sexual y esto sucede por un
simple motivo que es que no hablamos lo
suficiente al al respecto nuestra
sociedad ha normalizado la violencia de
género a la vez que ha convertido en
tabú la posibilidad de hablar sobre ella
y cuando hablamos sobre ella lo hacemos
de una manera que está totalmente
mediatizada por el cine la televisión o
los noticieros y el resultado es que
consumimos violencia sexual como si
fuese una forma más entretenimiento en
lugar de acercarnos a ella con empatía
esto tiene tres consecuencias cada una
peor que la otra y que se alimentan
mutuamente en un círculo vicioso
en primer lugar obliga a las mujeres a
vivir sus momentos más dolorosos en
silencio como si tuvieran que sentirse
avergonzadas de algo que ellas no
hicieron ni pidieron en segundo lugar
limita profundamente nuestro
entendimiento de la violencia sexual y
en tercer lugar impide que podamos hacer
algo real y efectivo para vencer esta
epidemia porque como vamos a cambiar
algo que ni siquiera sabemos cómo
reconocer
en un contexto así en el que las mujeres
nos hemos visto forzadas a vivir
nuestras historias de violencia en
silencio durante siglos romper ese
silencio no solamente es transformador a
nivel personal sino que es fundamental y
profundamente revolucionario a nivel
social
y es precisamente de eso de lo que
quiero hablarles hoy sobre cómo un día
un grupo de mujeres decidió romper ese
silencio y de lo que podríamos lograr si
es que este evento excepcional se
convirtiera en una norma
quizás muchos de ustedes hayan escuchado
hablar de él ni una menos
la marcha que se llevó a cabo del 13 de
agosto de este año si no participaron
probablemente vieron las imágenes en los
periódicos vuelos noticieros cientos de
miles de personas principalmente mujeres
tomamos las calles de la ciudad de la
capital y de todas las regiones del país
para hacer oír nuestra voz de protesta
frente a una sociedad machista y un
estado que en el mejor de los casos ha
sido indiferente con nosotras y en el
peor cómplice de nuestros agresores
según cifras oficiales fue la marcha más
grande de nuestra historia y si no
estuvieron allí pues va a tener que
confiar en mi palabra fue inmensa
conmovedora compleja e inolvidable
hoy sin embargo les voy a hablar de otra
cosa de algo que quizás no vieron en los
noticieros pues su poder no podía ser
capturado por una cámara de un proceso
mucho más silencioso aunque no por eso
menos poderoso que sucedió en las
semanas previas a la marcha
cuando decidimos convocar una marcha
nacional de mujeres hicimos lo que mucha
de mi generación hace cuando quiere
sacar algo adelante
entramos a facebook
en ese momento no sabíamos qué cosa iba
a suceder ni cuando nos movilizáramos
pero decidimos crear un grupo al que
invitaron nuestras amigas para comenzar
a organizarnos al comienzo éramos diez o
doce a las horas 600 un día después 2000
de pronto y no pasaron muchos días para
que esto sucediera para sucedió algo que
nunca hubiésemos podido imaginar una
mujer dejó un mensaje en el grupo que lo
cambiaría todo decía más o menos algo
así
creo que es fundamental dar un paso al
frente y salir del closet comenzaré yo
fui secuestrada violada varias veces y
torturada hace muchos años y hasta hoy
sufro de estrés postraumático por lo que
sucedió mi agresor fue condenado por
robo la violación no agravó el caso ni
fue tomada en cuenta
cuando elegimos esto en el grupo fue
como si las puertas de una represa se
abrieran después de siglos de haber
estado cerradas esas palabras en la
pantalla fueron un grito de rebeldía
contra el silencio que se nos ha
impuesto y contra el peso que nos vemos
obligadas a callar al que nos vemos
obligados a cargar cuando callamos
nuestras historias su declaración genera
una reacción en cadena imparable una por
una primero por decenas y después por
cientos las mujeres decidieron salir del
closet y comenzar a contar sus propias
historias de violencia
para ese momento y éramos un grupo de
más de 60.000 personas
si me pidieran que resumiera en una sola
frase lo que sucedió diría que fue como
un acto de alquimia que transformó el
silencio en sonoridad y el dolor en
empatía por primera vez pudimos hablar y
pudimos escuchar los historias que se
habían guardado en secreto durante años
o décadas de pronto dejaron de ser un
momento doloroso que vivir y revivir una
y otra vez en privado y se convirtieron
en testimonios no solo de violencia sino
es supervivencia y de resiliencia
las estadísticas de la violencia sexual
dejaron de ser estadísticas y se
convirtieron en mujeres de carne y hueso
mujeres como yo o como las que están
sentadas hoy en este auditorio mujeres
con historias mujeres imperfectas y
profundamente humanas
quienes tuvimos la suerte de vivir esa
experiencia pasamos semanas en una
especie de euforia transformadora y
catártica fue una experiencia única en
la vida una por una comenzamos a sanar a
través del poder de las palabras y los
testimonios
comenzamos a descubrir nuestras
historias en las historias de los demás
y a ver en el dolor de quienes ahí
escribían en nuestras propias historias
comenzamos a entendernos como parte de
una red de historias mucho más amplia y
que son tan únicas como profundamente
interconectadas por primera vez supimos
que no estábamos solas que estaba bien
hablar que otras mujeres podían y
querían escucharnos
cuando esta mujer decidió salir del
closet y romper ese silencio nos hizo un
regalo nos recordó que no es justo que
seamos nosotras las que cargamos en
silencio con el peso de local y más no
nos ha hecho como si tuviéramos que
sentir vergüenza o culpa por algo que
nosotras nunca pedimos nunca pedimos
ustedes se imaginan lo que es guardar un
secreto durante 20 años yo sí
si alguien me hubiese dicho hace cinco
años que un día sería capaz de pararme
frente a un grupo de desconocidos y
contarles la historia de mi agresión
sexual hubiese reído de ellos durante
demasiado tiempo me reduce a compartir
lo que me había sucedido con alguien
sentía mi vergüenza como si yo fuese
responsable de lo que me había pasado
como si yo y sólo yo tuviera la
responsabilidad de haber cometido donde
aparentemente no debí haberme metido y
de que un hombre adulto tocase mi cuerpo
de niña
pero lo que descubrí es que cuando
compartimos nuestras historias
comenzamos un ciclo de sanación que se
extiende más allá de nosotras hemos
pasado demasiado tiempo solas sin saber
que nuestras mejores aliadas se
encuentran justo al lado nuestro
la primera vez que yo compartí la
historia de mi agresión sexual
públicamente en un artículo recibí
decenas de mensajes de mujeres que nunca
habían hablado con nadie sobre lo que
les había pasado algunas eran mujeres
que yo conocía de toda la vida de mi
colegio de mi barrio y hasta en mi
propia familia cada una tenía una
historia distinta pero todos decían lo
mismo pensé que era la única
por eso cuando rompemos el silencio
decimos también que no vamos a seguir
aceptando que se nos niegue la
posibilidad de reconocernos unas en
otras como víctimas sí pero sobre todo
como sobrevivientes y si alguna ustedes
está escuchando esto y pensando en sus
propias experiencias solamente puedo
decirles una cosa que es que tengan la
certeza absoluta de que no están solas y
que sus aliadas están mucho más cerca de
lo que ustedes imaginan
el segundo problema que este silencio
genera es que limita profundamente
nuestro entendimiento de lo que es la
violencia sexual nos hemos acostumbrado
a una narrativa única de la agresión
sexual y es por eso que descartamos todo
lo que no se adapte a eso y es entonces
cuando comenzamos a preguntarnos pero
por qué no dijo que no porque no perdió
porque no grito porque no denunció
porque no se resistió
lo que la diversidad de los testimonios
en la página demostraron sin embargo es
que encasillar la agresión sexual en un
solo tipo de experiencia o en un solo
tipo de molde es imposible
desde los más escabrosos hasta los más
aparentemente cotidianos los testimonios
en el grupo demostraron que limitar
nuestro entendimiento de la agresión
sexual a lo que la mayoría de nosotros
imaginamos como una violación no
solamente es absurdo sino que impide que
podamos reconocer la verdadera extensión
del problema todos aquí estamos de
acuerdo en que una mujer que fue violada
y arrastrada por el suelo por su pareja
es una víctima de violencia nadie en su
sano juicio podría no estar de acuerdo
con eso
pero qué pasa con las demás historias
qué pasa con las formas con las
agresiones que son violentas de una
forma que no es tan gráfica ni visible
qué pasa con las formas de violencia que
la ley no tiene como tipificar ni
penalizar
por ejemplo qué pasa con esta historia
era mi amigo nunca lo había visto como
más que eso pero estaba un poco borracha
y la fiesta estaba divertida así que
terminamos besándonos cuando le dije que
ya me quería ir me dijo que pidiéramos
un taxi juntos que me llevaba a mi casa
nos subimos al carro pero en el camino
me pidió que fuésemos a su departamento
a tomar un último trago le dije que no
tenía ganas pero insistió y no quise
quedar como una creída en su casa
comenzó a besarme
le dije que no me gustaba esa forma que
era mi amigo pero no se detuvo cuando
volteaba la cara él me la cogía con las
manos y continuaba besando me comenzó a
quitarme la ropa y cuando le decía que
no me sentía cómoda me respondía ya pues
tú sabes que si quieres no sabía qué
hacer sólo quería que terminara quería
irme a mi casa me daba vergüenza
reaccionar con más firmeza él no está
haciendo nada malo no yo lo ves en la
fiesta y ahí estaba en su apartamento
dejar de resistirme era la forma de que
terminara más rápido
después me enteré de que le había dicho
a sus amigos que era dirigida y mala en
la cama
tal vez esta historia le resulta
familiar quizá hayan pasado por algo
parecido en más de una oportunidad ese
momento en que sí es cierto tal vez no
dijiste que no con la firmeza que te
hubiese gustado pero al mismo tiempo
sabes que lo no estuvo bien y sabes
también que la otra persona debió
haberlos sabido sin la necesidad de que
protestarán más fuerte pero porque no lo
supo
porque no protestas de más fuerte
la verdad es que las mujeres no
reaccionamos como se espera que
reaccionemos por million motivos porque
alguien en quien confía vamos y nos
repetimos una y otra vez que no sería
capaz de hacernos algo que nosotras no
quisiéramos
porque era nuestro jefe nuestro profesor
alguien más poderoso que nosotras un
hombre al que admirábamos
porque desde niñas se nos ha enseñado
que nuestro valor se mide por cómo nos
ven los hombres y porque francamente no
hay nada peor que una chica aburrida de
mojigata porque tenemos miedo a las
represalias porque sabemos que un hombre
molesto puede convertirse rápidamente en
un hombre violento y por eso hemos
aprendido a sonreír ya callar porque
tenemos miedo porque hemos aprendido a
sobrevivir
porque no sabemos qué más hacer
qué hacemos con estos casos lo primero y
lo más importante es hablar sobre ellos
muchas veces nosotras mismas ni siquiera
sabemos por qué hemos reaccionado de la
manera en la que hemos reaccionado y es
por eso que nos sentimos culpables
responsables y avergonzadas
pero lo que todas estas historias
demuestran es que existe un componente
estructuralmente violento en la forma en
la que hemos construido las relaciones
entre hombres y mujeres hemos engendrado
hemos hemos creado y normalizado roles
absurdos y dañinos que engendran formas
de violencia la idea de que las mujeres
siempre tenemos que hacernos las
difíciles y de que el que la sigue la
consigue y es por eso que muchas veces
cuando una mujer dice que no se siente
realmente incómoda los hombres piensan
que ella solamente está jugando el rol
que se espera de ella
el problema o la realidad es que la
única forma de entender esto es hablando
al respecto de lo contrario muchos ni
siquiera tendrán la posibilidad de saber
que algo que ellos consideraban una
interacción normal en realidad fue un
acto de violencia pocos días después de
la marcha conversaba con un amigo muy
querido sobre lo que había sentido al
leer los testimonios en la página
conversamos un rato y después me dijo
algo que nunca me voy a poder olvidar
yo nunca obligaría a una mujer a hacer
algo que ya no quisiera
o por lo menos es lo que yo creía porque
después de leer esos testimonios no
puedo evitar preguntarme si no estoy yo
ese hombre para una mujer si no he sido
yo el responsable de un encuentro que
otra persona recuerda de esa manera
la verdad
es que existen muchos tipos de violencia
o algunos tipos de violencia que no
vamos a poder eliminar pero otros que si
podemos cambiar con algo tan sencillo
como el poder de las palabras y de la
empatía no me malinterpreten con esto no
quiero decir que las leyes las
comisarías y los protocolos de urgencia
de atención no sean necesarios porque
son importantísimos y urgentemente
necesarios pero en la mayoría de los
casos ellos solamente solucionarán lo
que sucede después de una agresión la
única forma de cambiar la estructura que
permite que mucha de esta violencia sea
posible en primer lugar es rompiendo el
silencio y normalizando estas
conversaciones pero para eso necesitamos
primero aprender a escuchar necesitamos
crear entornos seguros donde las mujeres
puedan hablar sin sentirse juzgadas ni
agredidas y necesitamos tener las
conversaciones difíciles e incómodas que
francamente debimos haber tenido hace
mucho tiempo
nos merecemos mucho más de lo que
tenemos hoy y tenemos la obligación de
que este problema no se extienda
indefinidamente hacia el futuro
pronto llegará una nueva generación una
de lo que muchos que están aquí traerán
al mundo cuidarán y acompañarán a crecer
y es fundamental que esto suceda en un
entorno en el que estas conversaciones
sean normales frecuentes y promovidas
para que de esa forma puedan aprender a
relacionarse de una manera más
horizontal empática y sana la única
forma de lograr eso es hablando sobre
esto tenemos el poder de cambiar las
cosas y lo mejor es que podemos comenzar
a hacerlo desde hoy mismo estoy
absolutamente convencida de que tenemos
la herramienta para hacerlo y de que
ésta es tan sencilla cómo comenzar a
hablar
la mesa está servida así que hablemos
[Aplausos]